[MUSIC PLAYING]
Recognize this?
It's the dreaded ANR, the
application not responding
dialogue.
Android shows this
dialogue when an app
has taken more than five
seconds to return from an event
handler.
But why would that happen?
Well it's because the
UI thread is blocked.
It's waiting for something.
And since the UI thread
is the only thread
than can process input and draw
to the screen, when it stops
responding, so does your app.
So what can cause the UI
thread to just stop like that?
Well, the usual suspects
are system calls
that can block indefinitely,
like disk or network access.
These blocking calls are like
time bombs in your application.
Under normal conditions,
they might execute so fast
you barely notice them.
But with the right combination
of hardware and software
and luck, they explode.
My name is Ian
Ni-Lewis, and I'm going
to show you how to find
blocking calls in your UI thread
before they blow up on you.
Now the tool that can help us
here is called strict mode.
You can get to it by
going to Developer Options
and selecting
Strict Mode Enabled.
And when this option is
enabled, anytime a blocking call
is made on the UI thread, the
screen border will flash red.
Now that's the
strict mode alarm.
It signals a potential
performance problem.
For example, let's
say your app suddenly
decides to, I don't
know, load 90 bitmaps
during a scroll event.
With strict mode on,
you'll know about that
because you'll see
that red flash.
But there's more to strict
mode than just a checkbox.
Strict mode is actually a
flexible and fine-grained API
that gives you control over
what every thread in your app
is allowed to do.
It's kind of like a
run-time version of Lint.
Now using strict mode
means defining a policy
for one or more of the
threads in your app.
Now policy is an object that's
composed of two components,
a detection mask and a penalty.
Now the detection
mask is a set of flags
that defines the things that
you want to test for like disk
reads or network access.
The penalty tells
the system what
to do when any one of those
flag conditions are met.
The API in strict mode gives you
a whole set of penalty options,
from flashing the screen,
like we saw earlier,
to writing to the system
log, all the way up
to crashing your process.
You can also use strict mode
to respond to custom conditions
that you detect.
Let's say, for
instance, that you
know that one of
your methods is too
slow to run on the UI thread.
To detect that with
strict mode, you
call StrictMode.noteSlowCall
at the beginning of the method.
And make sure you enable
detectCustomSlowCalls
in the policy for the UI thread.
Now when detectCustomSlowCalls
is enabled,
a call to noteSlowCall
will raise an exception,
and then strict mode will apply
whatever penalty that you've
defined for that thread.
Now if detectCustomSlowCalls
is disabled,
then noteSlowCall is a NOOP.
Oh, here's a quick pro tip.
Call noteSlowCall whenever
you acquire a lock.
Why?
Well, locks are kind of
like stealth blocking calls.
They often return
immediately, so fast
that you don't even
notice they're there.
But if the lock is
contended, your thread
will get switched
out, with no guarantee
on when it gets to run again.
Now locks won't usually cause
an ANR all by themselves,
but if you call a
synchronized method
or acquire a lock
on your UI thread,
sooner or later you're
going to drop a frame.
Now strict mode also has
an API to set the policy
for the virtual machine.
That's the VM policy.
Now where the thread policy has
options for detecting slower
blocking methods, the
VM policy gives you
options for detecting various
kinds of memory leaks.
Now these two policies
complement each other.
Remember, if you're
low on memory,
even a normal
allocation can block
for hundreds of milliseconds.
Now chances are
there's at least one
blocking call on
your app's UI thread,
just waiting to
cause a glitch, a
dropped frame, or even an ANR.
Strict mode will help you
find those time bombs.
In an upcoming video,
we'll talk about how
to diffuse them, which is
why you need to check out
the rest of our Android
Performance Patterns
content for other ways to
improve your performance.
And don't forget to join
our Google community
for more excellent info.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]